okay now points inflection it's sort of
stationary points right first you're
gonna find it but then you don't really
determine their nature instead of
termini they nurture you fine and then
you confirm okay fine
okay finding works much the same way
okay how do you find a put inflection
first step what do you solve second
derivative is equal to zero so okay now
eventually if we find an opponent
function you are going to have to
substitute that back into Y to actually
get the coordinates okay before you do
that you actually want to confirm that
what you've got is a point of inflection
okay so this is my second part now how
do you confirm well we actually mention
this just before right you need to test
a second derivative behind side
okay so what you must have is the change
in concavity
okay yeah it's a theory so am I done
have I done I've solved this and I've
checked it I've confirmed it and sure
enough it checks out it's a point of
inflection am i finished that is you've
got it you've got to look again so this
is actually I put this under three right
when you're trying to find things right
look again what do I mean by look again
well graph it okay you have a general
sense of what this thing looks like okay
and what will come out is particular you
know points in flexure that don't come
up for this do you remember what app can
example what I think the most often
quoted one is the cube root of x sorry
that's a three okay remember what the
cube root of x looks like it's concave
down on this side and it's concave up on
this side okay at the origin where you
can see there's a point of inflection
change in concavity okay the first
derivative and the second derivative
they don't exist at that point okay so
therefore you've really got to be
careful with these ones if it's a
textbook question to say find the points
of inflection for this okay because
you'll solve for this and you'll find
there's no solution and then you pack up
and go home okay and you've missed the
point of inflection so solve confirm but
also actually have a think about what
this thing looks like okay yeah yes you
do yes she do okay all right so this
points of inflection this station okay
so if you are if this is if the question
was find any points of inflection for
this okay and the question didn't
actually say graph then absolutely like
I'll do this and it looks terrible and
there's no sense or anything on it but
it's enough to see oh yeah I've plotted
points and I've seen the concavity here
and the same on the other science would
say look there is a point of inflection